Buster Douglas shocked the world going
up against a man named Mike Tyson here's
a guy that could be at the top and beat
anybody do you ended up beating the guy
that everybody feared your mother had a
stroke and it passed away then think it
was gonna be a fight he comes in you're
looking at each other and I tell him I'm
ready to [ __ ] something up what was the
first time he hit you what was this like
any other punch she's only like 510 he
gets down kind of disappears and I got
relaxed that moment when I dare to stop
fighting and looking made me caught me
with that shot whoa [ __ ] so you go up
you fight and all of a sudden you know
you knock him out I never got a moment's
rest Don King was coming at me and guns
blazing I had to fight just to be called
the heavyweight champion of the world
[Applause]
[Music]
so on February 11 1990 a man named James
Buster Douglas shocked the world going
up against a man named Mike Tyson who
was 37 and no 33 knockouts no one gave
him any chance matter of fact the fight
was in Japan
commentators didn't even show cuz they
didn't think it was gonna be a fight and
he shocked them and he won the fight and
became a heavyweight champion of the
world
everybody around the world sat there
saying there's no way in the world this
happen and today's guest happens to be
the champ so James appreciate you for me
to guess here with us thanks for coming
out man
you got an incredible story I mean it's
not every day somebody wakes up and you
go against the odds that way they call
it the greatest underdog fight of all
time the biggest upset of all time
there's a there's a lot of upsets you
got The Miracle on Ice you know you got
one Ali went against Foreman they said
there's no way in the world he can go
against that punch but yours was a
different story you know you were kind
of quiet you'd vocal when you want it to
and like you know all these other events
that took place which we'll talk about
here today that led up to the fight but
before we get into this story you know
what are you up to know this what do you
do know this I'm back at Ground Zero
I started in the boxing you know amateur
program in Columbus Ohio which the city
runs and I'm part of that now and having
a great time working with the kids it's
like doing it all over again but now I'm
my father who was a coach when I was a
kid I'm coaching working with these
young youth coming up in Columbus let me
ask you do you love the game like you
know you know some people kind of
because I know your father was also
boxer and you kind of or boxer but do
you love the game of boxing I love the
game I have a strong feeling for you
know I really enjoy the competitiveness
of it you know show you more one-on-one
sport guy you also like to go I like the
group sports as well but what drew me
back to boxing was the competitiveness
because you know I was playing ball in
college
you know sometimes something like two or
three of the guys wouldn't show up
because of something they were going
through and you would need them and you
know they wouldn't be there for you so
that kind of drove me back to boxing and
that's why I came back to it as a pro
you know and 70 81 but before we going
to do the whole leading up to you and
Tyson growing up who was Buster Douglas
growing up if if if I was in school with
James who was James
I was one of the basketball players
athletes you know in high school and
throughout my lessons as well you know
normal peers you know who you were you
were you quiet like this there's parts
of you that you talk Smith but it's like
no one can get a read on you're like was
this guy's smack talker or if somebody
take you off you came out and said
something cuz I in the middle you were
in the middle yeah so you didn't have
enemies you you were kind of good with
everybody it was got it okay and and how
did you actually start picking up boxing
obviously I started when I was 10 year
old my father was a professional fighter
he was the first national Golden Gloves
champion in Columbus Ohio first ever
first ever you know I was like in 60-66
he won the national Golden Gloves in
Chicago that's when it was a big
tournament in Chicago and they took the
team from Columbus when's the terrors
migration center took a team to Columbus
I mean to Chicago and he was one of the
winners he came back as a national
champion
then he turned pro and had a pretty had
a successful pro career fought some of
the top fighters in the world then he
got overlooked a lot of times because
they didn't want to take a chance on you
know maneuvering their fighters to the
title fight and they wouldn't take my
father on because he was too big of a
risk
so as it was the way they do it in the
game you know they just picked the
fighters that they felt really strongly
there was a beat then moved around my
father a lot was he like a real-life
rocky type of guy you kind of didn't
want to fight him because he hate you
because you took heads off and right
and he was in great shape he was always
in great shaping and got you late you
got a lot of late round knockouts you
know eighth ninth tenth round yeah he
was sustained power and he was 160
pounds 6 foot you know middle way when
he fought middleweight and heavyweight
75 166 foot was he a disciplinarian
growing up or discipline but was he
tough on you guys cuz I know you and
your brother was you easy tough on you
or did he kind of not so much tough on
us because he seen your ability your
talent but he didn't really push you you
know and let it come to you you know he
always felt that I had the ability to be
a good pro fighter amateur fighter but
you know he let me do it at my wheel he
really never pushed me you know would he
push you got like it was there ever a
moment in your I know the story about
getting bully but was there ever a
moment where you kind of like you know
that I'm getting bullied in school and
he told you to go back and fight you
have a story of a bullying no yeah story
like that but it wasn't his involvement
it was my mother she was the one that
made me go out and fight the bullet
you know she slammed me on the ground
and telling me that we didn't fight him
he's not the father I had to fight her
she literally did that oh yeah I'll came
in the house sniffling crying and you
know she's seen this for the school's
right down the street we were on the
same side of the same street as the
school and I cross the main intersection
and I was walking down the street and
there's a group of kids behind me and I
was crying and you know I came in and
she's seen it the witness is on the
doorway when I walked in and she grabbed
me and slumming on the floor you know
telling running go out there and fight
that boy that I was gonna have to fight
her so it was like did you leave the
house or was it the next day the next
day it happened over again and I just
stood up dropped my books and said oh
that's it let's go and you went at it
with them and I went at it with him and
that was history so was the beginning
crazy yeah because all I said now miles
is bringing their kids over like your
son your son did to my kid you know I
just because they said something to me I
had to slow me down you know
Lulla Lulla
pearl yeah you you watch her the way she
looks at you man it was like when
there's you know some scenes of how your
mom actually looks at you you can tell
like this woman loves this I mean
obviously mother's love their sons but
the way she would talk about you the way
she looked at you was a whole different
story and so mom taught you toughness
did the technical side come from pops oh
definitely in the middle state as well
but he was really put it into the ring
aspect you know so would you go and
watch him fight with you somebody we
always want to see him fight when he
later in his career when we went I went
to Philadelphia with him when he fought
Matthew Franklin who bewitches became
Matthew sod Muhammad world light
heavyweight champion and I was at their
fight when they thought of the spectrum
and I also went to the fight when he
fought on the barber theater in New York
and the garden man event you know he was
the main event fighter man it was and he
always fought on the road and he always
went to the backyard the other fighters
didn't care what do you mean he always
went to the backyard well you know he
went to the ER then he went to there was
a neutral neutral zone it was I didn't
matter you go right in your backyard
fight you let me ask you was built your
grandfather was is there lineage of
boxing or no he's the first one that my
grandfather fought and then in the Navy
you know he fought as an amateur in the
Navy and that's what my father picked it
up from and then I just picked it up
from my dad so she's almost like he was
a lobby city living through you seeing
what you were doing you know what he
taught me Pro and I think I had my first
22 so fights I was with my dad as a
problem man
after that I got involved with John
Johnson and that's where we just really
took off and started to make it make big
waves in John Johnson bojong Johnson
he's got a personality of his own he is
he always like that is he always finds
all in loud like
always cursing I mean you watching me
like he needs a reality TV show himself
because he's so interesting just
listening to him but let me ask you
James would you say you were a classic
story of a guy who had abilities but he
needed somebody that got the best out of
him and he was able to do it with you is
that what is that what it was with you
because it almost like when you follow
your career here's a guy that could be
at the top and beat anybody right you
you could beat could beat anybody see
you ended up beating the guy that
everybody feared you just beat anybody
you'd be the guy he'll be some guys
leading up to that too now I wasn't just
given - no you were not there's a list
of guys you get into yeah the top ten
and you know I felt some top competitors
- we're all in line to get a shot yeah
so you have to beat one another to come
out on top to see who's gonna become the
number one number together so I think
you were ranked fourth when you fought
Tyson nobody - oh you were - when you
fought ties I was fourth in one it was
like three bodies no sex anybody's gotta
I was - three or four got it so you were
up you with the guy that I'm and it was
like you know I deserved a shot because
when like I was walking down the street
and I always say this donkey was driving
down Avenue that see me hey big guy you
wanna fight for the title of the night I
earned that shot but docking was also
not a big supporter of you he was but he
wasn't it would almost seem like he was
not ready to body form
he was just yet that's what it sounds
that time Tyson was proving that he was
a gentleman and so I was just a
sacrificial lamb basically but you
messed him up
like yeah you probably kind of master
plan yes you did you mess the plan up
because that could have been a
moneymaker for many many years - oh yeah
you know it's almost like you took his
confidence away because his
invincibility laughs because it you know
it's a different story when you have a
guy comes up you know I think Ali lost
six fights I want to see him that I've
been like 50-something at six so he had
a feel of fights he lost former lost
Holyfield lost you know a lot of these
guys lost but the way Tyson was coming
up it was invincible it's like very near
future no way so in in that
puts the kind of pressure of perfection
where you know when a person that seen
everybody is telling her he's perfect
when he loses how do you believe the
people that are telling you you're so
perfect I'm not perfect I lost so
Mayweather yes say he has an undefeated
career and he talks but I'm the only guy
that's bit rocky Marcia what ever the
record that he owns for being undefeated
but but it's a different story of what
you did with Tyson but the question I
wanted to ask is how much of a role was
it you finding somebody that got the
best out of you well given what John was
a big part of that because you know I
think we kind of connected you know we
believe in I believe to him and he
believed in me in and I seen that he was
definitely out to be a winner and he
brought that spirit to the to the
partnership you know because he was a
Woody Hayes guy you know he wasn't
having it you know you're gonna do this
right or we're not gonna do it at all
how did he talk to you one-on-one
I would help what was his language for
the most part it was you know straight
up you know just conversation but you
seen it sincerity in his eyes in his
voice but sometimes you get really nasty
and mean but it was very few times you
did that but he did when he knew he did
that he was that his in how nasty like
it's pretty [ __ ] you know like okay
God so you know throwing stuff you know
in front of you right any see real upset
did you react to that did that kind of
man I knew that it was legitimate that
he really meant what he's saying is it's
expressed in our sincere he was and you
know he was just tired of the BS at
times you know so this this a lot of the
wedding directed at me was just as some
of the times that we had to go through
to get to that point you know because of
the negotiations for example between him
and a promoter but what's he ever like
you know you look at coaches and players
right you look at Tyson the relationship
he had with cus you know you look at all
these guys the relationship they have
with somebody that comes in that just
knows how to get through them right what
would you say that was the case okay and
what was the entrance to you was it
through your heart was it through here
was a true belief was it true
to my heart and as well as my mind you
know it was like I've seen the sincerity
I felt he really meant and they believed
in me you know and then the things that
I've noticed that he had to go through
getting certain things for me that was
nobody believed in me you know I've seen
a sincere Dean and it was just you know
you've seen the desire in the will and
sometimes it wouldn't work out and he
would be upset what was a negative
motivation a positive motivation oh so I
thought the most part it was positive
but what I'm saying is like hey I don't
think you really wanted you know I I
don't think this do you really want to
be the champ like was it like that or
did that make me laugh because I was you
know it doesn't do nothing to you right
but you know on the other hand it was
just you know where he would just be
talking and you know I would see that it
was just genuine mm-hmm you know
[Music]
interesting so who was on your team I
know was him it was your uncle who the
assistant who was your team it was John
Johnson JD McCauley and John Russell
what role did each play with you John
Johnson was a manager and JD and John
Russell were the trainer's really John
Russell was like the trainer trainer JD
was my you got got me up every morning
to run and he would talk to me
spiritually in the morning and
throughout the throughout my career once
we got together about he knew that he
wouldn't be doing this he was didn't
believe in me I knew that I could do it
I knew you got the ability to do this
but you just got to maintain your focus
and put the effort in and it's gonna
happen for you you know cuz I mean we
get up at 5:30 in the morning you know a
run and then some mornings his wife
would be to our Betty would be there
driving the car you know having the
lights on while we're driving down the
street Wow you know so it was a task but
we did it man and I'm telling you was
you know in the wintertime when the snow
was everybody else was told to stay in
the house you know because the weather
severe blows
running oh I seen you running with
snoring your face was the best the best
time some of my best times home is on
Iran - so so one was how to your trainer
one was business one was spiritual is
that a good way of putting it that was
it that was it did they all each
individually know how to work together
like yeah you know growls you know we
let one talk at the time when everybody
mumble together jumbled together was
just you know they were neutral respect
for one another
what's the idea like hey guys let's work
together to be able to move this guy
that was just something that really just
gradually happened it all came together
for one man effort it was me and that
made me feel even better because I bet I
knew the mango was you know everybody
was there for me it wasn't each other
let me ask you something that JD did and
just out of curiosity for myself I
watched some of these guys because at
that time when you were doing fights how
much were you getting paid per fight
that you had pre pre holyfield pre Tyson
a few hundred dollars fifteen hundred
dollars twenty four so how much are
dating how much is JD making how much
are these guys man well Jamie was the
one thing taking any money he said
unbelievable yeah yeah he's just gonna
take it at the end when you get that
when you become a chance yeah when we
come a champ or is that a verbal
agreement or was a verbal these guys
really believed in you like they're
hundred percent Jay trusted Douglas
trusted me
did you ever because when you have a
father with that kind of a you know a
presence that kind of a toughness
himself
did he ever push you around like did you
guys ever have an altercation was there
ever a moment where you know you pushed
it a little too far and he got in your
face and you guys went at it was there
ever a relationship like that was just I
wouldn't do that to my dad you know
because one it was bill Douglas then two
is my father you know it was just he was
just that type of guy did you mom play a
big role in mom played a wonderful role
and
because she was doing and made everybody
else shut the shut up and listen she was
the man when I got too ridiculous if it
ever did I would talk to her and she was
just like between me and my dad where it
would be like I can't get through to him
he's not listening
I worry mom and then she was coming
along you know we sit at the kitchen
table me her my father even when I
decided to leave my dad and go with John
I had to bring her in to talk you know
she was like all he was there one day
and I was at the other end of the table
she was in the middle she didn't say
anything but she was there presence you
know so that made me comfortable where I
knew he was gonna no doubt go off and
you know in the way that I thought maybe
it could happen but you know then works
out great so and obviously in this case
for it to be that effective your dad had
a lot of respect for your mom almost
definitely did it was a love was it pure
love love love love there was no doubt
yeah that's obvious because because he
could have easily been an aggressive
crossing the line type of guy because a
lot of times boxers have that kind of a
reputation for the family he was known
for that you know he had you know strong
personality did he have a temper as well
or not yeah except that's why in the
family yeah you know that's what it was
it was so nice because he's silly with
us growing up he was a comedian you know
but once he walked out that door I was
like you transform you know nobody never
got to see that side of my father did
you ever see him get into a street fight
or no no he never got into a street
fight it seemed that no were people no
listen I'm just then the one that really
knew in cotton grass man so that goes
back to high school when he ran track
he ain't before track me I was running
and got sick and went out in the field
the football field and you know I
started throwing up when they try that's
what I that's where has a nickname
grassman was with your dad amount of
faith or was he more just discipline
military like the you know the extremely
hard-working guy was he extremely hard
worker hard-working guy got it got it
so you you transition to the story about
you going home and
sit down with your mom and your dad
that's post Tucker fight right I think
it's right after right well that was
that was when Johnny and I had just
gotten together and we were just making
my plans and doing what we were doing
you know transitioning then becoming a
team and you know our dad was you know
calling and telling it you know messing
with one man his family is not good and
then John immediately wanted to shut it
down where I wasn't even gonna go
because he was afraid of my father
because you know he filled me missing
with one man's family I don't well it
was like because that's when I told my
dad that I was gonna start working with
John he's it's pre Tucker or post Tucker
this is a pre talked pre Tucker this is
when the beginning when John and I got
together you know after probably was 84
and we were just getting together I'm
tell my dad that I was gonna go another
direction and I was no longer need him
to direct my career I was gonna let John
Johnson do it was Tucker like at that
time if you had to pick a name so you
know some of the some folks watching is
they don't know who Tucker was at the
time who was Tucker when you went
against him he was the number one
contender right in the heavyweight
division in IBF and at that time I was
the number two heavyweight contender
Larry Holmes was supposed to fight
somebody and didn't want to fight
everything they stripped him of that IBF
del Sol they had the number-one and
number-two contender fight for the title
come on I was Tucker and I so and and
you had him yeah I mean yeah I was
wondering I was doing really well yeah
fight but see that was our dad was
involved at that time and it was a
pretty tough training experience because
he would come to the gym wouldn't allow
nobody to say anything but he was like
chief training and you know he'd say
something and then like JT would say
something any daddy say
will you be quiet
maybe like arguing with each other so
that was a tough trendy smash you know
that was what her comfortable how much
of it was I know he went into the fight
wearing his shirt name you know he would
employ any bill Douglas shirt right
everybody else had James yeah everybody
how much if that was for you to kind of
be like listen you know you know I
understood that nothing bother me I
didn't bother me at all that was just my
dad
you knew him already right yeah I was
aware that but everybody else is like
whoa you know and I didn't really come
out until after their fight so you know
that was just my dad that was just here
that didn't bother you now they didn't
bother the only thing that bothered me
about the situation was that he wouldn't
get along with conform and relax and let
people be themselves you know he had it
I wrote tense everybody was scared to
say anything because they thought it
popped or something you know yeah
because his presence was that strong so
when you had the conversation with pops
okay you you you you beat Tucker you're
gonna go faceoff and you know champion
the whole night right so you're right
there but then this happens I think 10th
round or whatever happens though you you
lose the fight and then post you go have
the conversation with your mom and your
dad you have to sit down and then
immediately what happened after that I
go back to the drawing board and start
over again because at that time that's
one of the times Don was really backing
me he was pushing me the win this fight
you know you're not ended up coming up
short man you know it was kind of like
fill me to the wayside you know I was
just a pawn now but your trainers were
still loyalty oh yeah they were long
they knew that I had the ability to do
it that it was just had to be everything
had to be right in which it has to be
you know go out there and put it
together and do the things to do to be
champion or win post Tucker you're going
to win streak legitimate six six fight
win streak yeah six fight and so who was
the sixth fight right before Tyson
Oliver McCall so you go through all
three Oliver McCall and my
because they both were talking antennas
and I had to fight both of them you went
through both of them how intense was
your training at this time it was great
everything was going along you know
training was good today
everybody mentally was focused and
comfortable you know it was just a big
but everybody was relaxed you know we
just got busy
I have no distractions are you making
money at this time yeah so you are
making money at this time so the fights
are the bouts are how much are the
fights you're fighting first put it a
hundred thousand okay okay so there's
some money being made with the purses
okay got it so now you you get to point
you won the sixth straight McCall or
whoever it is that you went then how
does this lead to the fight with Tyson
who reaches out this well I'll call you
what is well we were supposed to go to
leading up to the February fight we were
gonna go to October Canada he was doing
Tyson was gonna defend his title against
Ray's already and we were training to
lose on a fight on the undercard and
that fight fell through so then they
moved on to the next next that came back
a product month later I said well we're
gonna fight in February and then turns
out that it was they would put me and
with Tyson in February we were gonna go
to Tokyo because of a fight with him and
Redick was gonna be in Canada but like I
said that fight fell through so then the
next fight was me fighting and fighting
Tyson in Tokyo so you get the call is
this like right John gets a call comes
to the gym and said we're next
what was the reaction when you heard
that it was great it was like you know a
beat but I was happy about it you know
then it was like tell you a lie Tokyo
cuz nobody here in the United States we
didn't want to fight so we were just
take it over to Tokyo
James I've heard a lot of different
reasons why they went to Tokyo what is
your assertion on why they went to talk
low and then think it was gonna be a
fight they thought was gonna be a quick
one like they couldn't sell it I guess
the hard sell you know I was winning but
I wasn't
by that time Tyson had such a you know
he was just taking guys out you know the
legitimate you know Spinks homes you
know legitimate fighters and I wasn't in
that ranking as far as the public eye I
was always right there the middle of it
but like I said he wasn't decapitating
anybody he didn't have a chance against
this man you know when the call was made
and he comes to you and tells you listen
we are next was there a sense of
enthusiasm anxiety was what was the
emotions I mean what or was a like okay
it's good it's here what I mean the
smile says a story right there so what
did you think when he said that to you
but I know the reaction yes my mom was
getting phone calls you know this
happening is this true you know because
you know he was a minute I mean he's
done some things that were just
incredible you know people that you
thought was gonna really compete with
him he would just blow him out mmm
were you at all afraid no I was there I
fought under six under cars and I co
featured a couple of them you know
meaning I fought before he fought just
before he fought in uh you know
successful and but then like I said it
was like if you hadn't really you know
by literally breaking bones or something
you I'm even considered to be have a
chance against this man because he was
just like a terminator
I sure would this story is what the day
he won right before you want to fight as
well in seventh round and you know
everybody was kind of saying wow listen
Tyson did win but let me tell you here's
what happened also with James Buster
Douglas you want to fight the same exact
day right that you had to five different
places but you want the same no no same
exact place on the car under car got it
so that you still had a talk like people
some of the guys that were in the world
were saying you know this guy's kind of
trying to make the climb to get the
fight so now you get the fight okay so
the fights taking place you guys gotta
go gotta go to Tokyo did you do most
your training here pre Tokyo oh yeah you
did all the trainer's you wanna talk to
you we had to be there two weeks before
I was on the training I did in Tokyo was
the two weeks before the fight and
really it was like a week so that week
before the fight the
we gotta fight is just basically public
workouts press conferences you know it's
just cool down period just rested I'm
getting ready for the fight itself is
that typical by the way that's typical
so right a week before the fight you're
not really going at I love intensive
relaxing and God are you watching any of
the media of what's being said are you
your family anybody not use everybody
telling me you know then when I did
watch it it wasn't good so when you said
you did and it wasn't good like it
discourage you where you're getting up
no it was pissing you off right and I
say the one thing they don't realize
about this fight is that folks we're in
the fourth round were in the fifth round
you know because they all thought it was
gonna be one or two two rounds doesn't
mean that's just I was now you know when
I remember your fights like when I
remember the story of what happened with
Buster Douglas I kept hearing about
where the motivation came from like
where did this guy like you were taking
part like you were you were you were
incredible in that fight like you were
determined to win this fight and then
there's a story of what happened on
January 18 to 1990 which is 23 days
right before the fight right when this
story happened walk us through what
happened there and how you reacted to it
we pride right my mama passing she came
over to the house
and you know I was there by myself and
and she came in and we sit down and she
said she just wanted to talk about the
fight cuz he went out and bought that
book that might had out that Mike had
out just before our fight and you know
pretty intense book you know its
mentality and so she was talking with me
about how I was you know how she wanted
to see how I was thinking and you know
how things were going with me because I
was going through a lot at the time too
and then after we talked she was like oh
my god you so mean you know but she was
satisfied she was convinced that I was
gonna give it that I was focused and
really ready to fight this fight that I
wasn't just
another one of the sacrificial lambs
that everybody thought so she was
convinced she told her girlfriends I'm
not worried about Buster he's gonna beat
Mike you know all I'm came up to me and
told me that I'd to the fight her
friends you know two or three of her
friends can we talk your mother said
he's gonna beat him buster you know and
they were like shocked that she said
that because they seen or heard of this
guy
you know that's how he's at the top of
his game you know she always believed me
your brother tells the story of your mom
going to your dad and talking to him and
saying hey you know is this guy as bad
as people make him out to be
well she said is he bad as you see bad
as you yeah he said yes yes he is honey
you'll see his dear what is what is
gonna be what Buster and what he's
saying yeah you could do it Wow so who
called you when when the event happened
with your mom
JD JD call because he was at the house
and my mother's and father's house then
when I got over there he was outside
presenting we're going in the house
because I mean my dad was on edge so I
wouldn't talk to him insane when I came
in the house they were taking her out on
the gurney
it's the first thing you saw when he
came in the house no the first thing
that my father then when I went back
well no I walked in and my brother Bo
again I went I went to the bedroom she
was on the bed they had her covered up
and I pulled on the cover you know I
could look at it but I couldn't really
pull this I mean you know do it so what
was your immediate reaction
it was my mom you anger anger was the
first reaction ya know do so much for
hmm I got to see we're looking forward
to giving for all these girls yeah I was
take care of you know this was the
payday this is it I knew I was gonna win
I felt strong feel good about it but I
knew that I had to stay strong that just
made it even more intense was everybody
coming to you saying hey you know James
this is this is you may want to postpone
the fight this this maybe not JD asked
me say well what do you want to do I
said I'm a fight fight this right just
made it even more intense the
determination level go to a whole
different level immediate it was already
kids don't know ha but it went higher
you know it was there the whole time I
was in great shape I was ready to fight
3 weeks 3 4 weeks outside I was ready I
was ready girl had a great training that
just made it even more it just brought
it even together even more the next 23
days like was every training and
everything you did was your mom on your
mind the entire time while you were
going through training mostly after
between before and after once I was in
the gym I was focus on what I was doing
but then afterwards there was downtime
that was you know kind of tough so the
downtown were you up you were down were
you kind of like no I was downtown no
training just right right but but the
downtime were you trying to figure out a
way to hold it all together or I was
ready
by myself but he just encouraged me even
more Buster's dude when it was coming to
the fight that the media note that this
your mother had a stroke and it passed
away or the media that's what it really
looked bad for me in their eyes you know
how can we compete with this mother
whose mother just passed so it really
didn't look good so there they even made
the odds worse to say there's no way
this guy can win this fight right maybe
even you know no contest type it's such
a Wow Wow that's interesting so that's
even more heartless you know all you
care about is the story they don't know
significance they don't see deep into
what was going on a possibility that can
happen even with the event you were the
media was being heartless with this well
yeah you know it was just a story that's
what I said heartless it wasn't like any
compassion about the situation they were
just wanting to get this story now no
matter what you know they didn't care
the main focuses mic anyway
leading up to the fight any other events
took place leading up to the photo who
did that 23 days go by very quickly same
Oh outside of my mother's passing it was
just you know just working out getting
ready so fight he comes what are you
thinking how you feeling feeling great
you know didn't wait to get in there
I wanted to bust something up you would
that determined by me yeah you literally
couldn't wait to get in there yeah
looking forward to it was was was
umbrella Robert was with me he would
come in and sit buzz what's up man how
you feeling you know I tell him I'm
ready to [ __ ] something up and he'd be
like we started laughing and stuff I
tell my man was your dad at the fight as
long no I was just
Robert Robert daughter when I would whip
me
the rest of my family over my job
Johnson's wife his son and JD's wife
came over I don't know was she walking
into the ring you entered away to get
there so you're in he comes in you're
looking at each other now I wasn't even
looking at it you're filling a ring out
soon where somebody saw Solly all the
way around
she's ready to go I feel great in that
moment are you wanting to hurt him are
you determined to implement which you
guys have been training in the training
camp is it just pure strategy I'll put
it put the game plan together go to work
how you coming on nerves how are you
coming to nerves oh you do that just
right you know once the bell rang once
you get in there and you feel it
everything you know that the main thing
with the nerves is once you get in there
you know you know put in the work and
effort there's nothing to be nervous
about you know you can lie and tell
everybody using best trainers training
camp bead in hand and you feel really
good and then get in there and that's
when it all the true comes down you
ain't ready even bullshitting around
you've been faking everybody else up
yeah and this guy look ready you know
that was the last thing on my mind I was
ready I was ready to go so the
confidence came from the level of
preparation yeah exactly so fight starts
you've never felt this punch before what
was the first time he hit you when you
said I can take this I can I can handle
this did you was there a moment you
remember it like any other punch hit hit
before it wasn't you know it was just a
sea of speed and then he's only like 510
and you know he ducks and he gets down
he kind of disappears he makes this
quick move to the left or to the right
and you know he's coming and he's coming
up with launching into you with the
hooks in right hands
was he the hardest hitter ever no never
it wasn't the hardest hitter he was in
the hardest hitter at all seriously I'm
serious who was the hardest hitter ever
I had a spiral partner that was like 135
pounds that was you know good white
Tyson and
you know can hit really hard is great
friend of Mines Darnell Hayes he was we
came up together he had really hard to
but he just you know didn't had a focus
and stuff you know
yeah well I'm hit harder you know but
it's just his intensity Tyson's
intensity and determination is what
really got in the way it was because he
was just an intense guy did the speech
shock you or it was was your Hayes was
your training partner fast what are you
almost ready for you three three great
sparring partners you know and they were
pretty good fighters as well you know
you get guys and up and coming
I went through a few at first but then
when I got these three guys they really
worked out and we kept him they worked
out so they came to work every day put
it on me and you know got me in great
shape so when you when the fight starts
and you fight him in look it pretty much
every round you took I except for the
one that he I think the eighth round he
took but if you went six seven rounds
you've taken everyone at him on points
right landing 53 percentages so I see
the scorecards had me had a tire or had
me you got to be kidding me
yeah it was incredible so if you don't
knock him out yeah when they have a draw
you may lose I was you don't not come
out you lose didn't look that way I know
but have been the biggest farce in all
history of sports well it's common in
boxing it didn't be the freedom that
would happen and it was really common a
lot with my father fought because it
wasn't TV so he was just radio and you
know you can really see what so was
there a point was there a turning point
in the fight will you said I'm winning
this thing
yeah when was that a frown after you got
up
no a frown is when I when I did like
this is a lot of beauty there and I got
relaxed that moment when I did stop
fighting and looking man he caught me
with that shot it was like whoa well you
almost shocked when you got you with the
hook OD up yeah
yeah I was like damn you know now that
saying I was on my back looking at like
oh [ __ ] you know that moment that brief
moment I wanted to have a moment to
reflect in the middle of a killer fight
when I have a moment to reflect and got
caught so you're done so the intensity
was there he was ready he was looking
for the opportunity yes I think it
almost seemed like he knew he's not
gonna go the whole thing he's got to
take you out so he almost I made it
count hoping you wouldn't get up right
right and I've seen when I got up and
looked at him in the air just seemed to
do right out of him like it's almost
like that was the tipping point it's
interesting they're saying that it's
almost like that was a tipping point
when you watch the fight who did you say
in your corner saying I got this don't
worry about it I got this you see Tolson
did you tell somebody in your corner dad
it's over with I'm won in this fight
because I think John or somebody said
that he came into Carter's on Johnson in
the back and says well then go get him
you know what your John John said he's
scared to death
he said he's scared yeah John said ties
him scared oh that was that was prior to
the night now when he said that let me
ask you this technical question you know
the whole thing where Don King afterward
said it's 13 seconds as 12 state did put
the whole video and they start doing the
counting thing you know the spectacle
that they did if he counted slow the ref
because you know they said the ref
counted really slow with you and really
fast with them if he counted slow you
seemed conscious so you could have
gotten of whatever time start wait until
8:00 9:00 okay you just gotta stay
focused and take the time do a quick
body check but Darlene I'll get ready
get up then I just lay back relax which
is what you're supposed to use the chart
on to the rest I know I had eight to get
up so eight I got up strong you know did
a quick body check like I'm still here
focus I know where I'm at you know got
on up so you go up you fight you throw
the punches and all of a sudden you know
you knock him out immediate reaction are
you saying it's over he's not getting up
no I thought he was gonna get up only
time I figured it was over
singing crawl to get his mouthpiece
that's what I knew he was incoherent so
though we all know that you got to get
up to get that count stop and when I
seen him reaching for that mouthpiece I
knew that he was he was hurt this is
over first reaction it's over he's
hugging him you know he's hugging the
yeah the referee dream come true all the
years of dreaming and finally succeeding
was awesome awesome experience I'm
telling it was a great great moment in
my life until you know like hearing my
name called as the undisputed
heavyweight champion of the world
you know the hoopla all the team coming
in there congratulating me and once we
got out the ring and then got back to
the dressing room then the nightmare
began because then they started saying
that came in and said they're protesting
a fight
well you're surprised that Dante go and
do something like that I was really
surprised oh you were surprising who'd
do something like that yeah he had a
reputation of being yeah you know but I
didn't think that was I had no I have no
idea was gonna be like that cause it was
legitimate when did that take any that
Thunder out or no you still felt the
victory in oh definitely won on Johnny
Carson you were on all these different
shows yeah it was definitely I knew he
couldn't take it because it was on world
tark world-class TV now I was back in
the day where it was like radio he might
have gotten that off but by being on
national TV with a world seeing that it
was like no way in hell are we gonna go
for this everybody's seen it you know
nobody was celebrating as well Buster
how much of this do you think had to do
with your mother's passing 23 days prior
to that but do you think whether that
happens or not you're winning the fight
or do you think dad I haven't gone on
before that you know I was very positive
and
like I said with the training was going
really well but you know it was just you
know so I'm just added to it but I was
ready to go prior to that of her passing
so regardless you think you would have
won the fight 3 then kind of gave you
the tolerance to take endure little bit
I can't say something like that with a
man if it was going any other way if the
training was rough preparation was
doubtful and something like that would
have happened it had been over literally
been just like really a reason not to
continue but I was going great and
strong and that just shows you that
everything was going it was it was lined
up that was the plan it just made it
even go through even more because you
know I wasn't having a great training
session and things weren't going well
with her passing that would have really
dissolved it you know made it being like
no no - got it but by me having a great
training session we had been in the gym
for eight weeks you know leading up to
that fight you know and then she passed
two weeks prior to the fight so first
question I was asked right after the
fight you you you gave love obviously to
your mom and immediately you broke down
in a moment how many times have you
watched that moment with the fight like
have you yourself ever sat down by
yourself and watched a fight from
beginning to the end and seen her
several times several times yeah by
yourself no free nobody yourself how do
you react when you watch that fight now
like when you watch it what is your
reaction it just takes me back every
every moment comes up every every
movement every it all just this
naturally just comes up to where I just
I see the feel the intensity and what I
was thinking at that time and
determination it's a great feeling James
you fly back your dad's not at the fight
the first moment you make eye contact
with your dad what's what's his reaction
did you did it baby so proud of you
it was like he handed the ball off to me
I'd leave with time and I took it all
the way all the way to the top pinnacle
there's not above anything heavyweight
champion against a guy that's arguably
one of the most feared boxers of all
time you know Holly wasn't Ali was there
was Sonny Liston exactly it's a whole
different story with what he did so how
does it feel how's it feel knowing you
you beat the most feared guy in the
world like he's great because I always
knew I had the ability to do it and then
actually succeed at it you know just
like it was meant to be was there ever a
doubt with you you're not a doubt guy
like did you you a doubt person yourself
were you ever questioning your ability
to be able to pull it off or no you're
confident are confident that's not your
wire and interesting very interesting
because 42 to one man I mean listen when
you break down math 42 to one that's not
like you know a 1001 that's crazy odds
like there's no way that guy's gonna win
10/10 122 won it's an insult 42 to 1
it's like don't even go to the fight and
really and really 42 to 1 is basically
like let's just put it there that's
really unbelievable tight like you said
unbelievable type odds because it wasn't
even books on it at all on the fight
that's why we're in Tokyo you know it
was just a quick one you know quick wash
you know game a little tune-up before he
goes to the big fight or something they
said a one-person bet a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars on Mike Tyson to
win $4,000 somebody bet a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars and if Tyson
would have won the winning is only going
to be four thousand that's 42 that's
insane to me that's insane to me that
means something somebody bet 4,000 on
you day 160 there's some other bets 160
on Tyson they went 4000 so no in Vegas
was saying they only had a few people
that were betting on you
literally nobody was betting on you you
know one guy brags about the fact that
he did there's a group of guys I like to
brag that I'm one of the guys that bet
on you know James 42 to 1 so then right
after that you come home 25,000 people
show up or hi your craziness they cannot
believe oh my gosh just got pulled it
off you know how are you taken by your
community now like you know what was
that reaction when even the local places
you would go to the restaurant you would
go eat the gym you would go to the the
coffee shop or places you typically go
to the routine barber shop how would
they treating you I knew after
such-and-such around you know I've seen
the determination you know do you do you
pay for coffee when you go places do
they take your money today like I was in
Panama and I went to Roberto to Ron's
restaurant cuz you know when he won
himself he was God in Panama and this
story is like these guys welcome this
guy he became you know yeah yeah I got
to do for Alberto hanging Hector Comacho
and his comeback hangout was like even
Tyson says a lot of the things he picked
up from do Ron like he says I learned a
lot yeah he's a monster
psychological monster wartime champion
of four different weight classes that's
that's insane insane you started at a
hundred thirty-five pounds went up to
like 75 and these timings winning titles
incredible fighter man yeah when you
talk to pros and they say hey give me
the top ten of all time almost everybody
has him on the list
no God who are your top five top five
greatest boxers of all time you put your
Carlos Monzon Victor Glen des Tommy
Hearns interestingly yes I mean it goes
back I mean
and I'm you guys again tomorrow tell you
another set of fire hose a Nepalese
you know well away champion great
waterways champion back in the seventies
sixties and seventies Sugar Ray Robinson
you've been listening on that list you
put Foreman on that list you put Frazier
on that list or no I'll put Frazier on
there but I wouldn't put a listing or
former you put Tyson top ten top five is
he top five or top top six top six kind
of interesting interesting go now and
your fan today are you following when
there's fights like oh you watch a
release fight tonight a champ that's
gonna be a good one I'm going with
Pacquiao I think you gonna take that kid
in in a deep-water late fight and drown
yeah pakia is a interesting beast are
you also from the narrative that
Mayweather avoided the fight with
Pacquiao at his peak or you don't come
from that school of thought was
incredible he's three generations of
world champions you know well uncle was
a world champion father was a great
fighter but he in and out of trouble but
you know a long time he's definitely he
did it right now and by the way the guy
is uh you know he's a strategist I mean
he it's a street kid that you would be
like he's a punk the guy is extremely
smart winning I know him in 57 would go
back and hey learn how to read and do
all this other stuff they do but he he
knew how to control the narrative very
well you got to give that guy props for
that side he found my brother Artie and
uh amateurs we took the team from
Columbus up to Grand Rapids Michigan
when you saw him fight as a amateur even
then did you say this guy is going to go
the distance award no I was pissed so he
be arty but you know what I'm thinking
about it like that damn but
he's been the champion all this room
career yeah interesting
so eight months after your fight with
Tyson you fight Holyfield and
Holyfield's fight doesn't end the way
you want it to end
yeah you end up losing just I was how
could he gave Holyfield my best cuz I
know that's why I chose him to fight
I couldn't easily went with forming or
someone else but I wanted to fight
Holyfield and then you know continue to
just destroy these guys that were
supposed to be you know top fighters you
know but by the time when I had to go
through see I went through a long legal
litigation with Don King right I just
moment of that fight was here my name
announces a new I just move the
heavyweight champion and then after that
it became a nightmare because I flying
all over the country you know trying to
figure out where the court case is gonna
be and I was in front of lawyers the
whole time why are you part of it
because I had to give my the 12 second
deal did that the testimony I call you
in lawyer to call you in and talk to you
about you know what was my side what did
I my side of the story you know flying
around city state the state you know why
you know you're the fighter wouldn't
that be the federal wouldn't that be BD
you know I have three law firms I had to
start talk to about the end of the fight
court case is gonna be in Vegas LA or
New York
so three law firms and I had to fly
around and talk to about what happened
during a fight and then I was out of
lawyer the contracts and you know then
it being held in New York you know
became very sad and depressing business
all the way to your fight yeah it's like
you know six eight weeks eight weeks two
weeks before the Holyfield fight and we
settle out of court and then it was like
go riding and training and a pair of the
defendant title you got paid you got a
good payday that was pitiful because
should've been a lot more payday you
think they should have been more than
that number well I'm just saying
legitimately annually or yeah I might
have been did
normal well you take a little two or
three months vacation and then prepare
for your next fight like any other time
but miles was nothing like that because
I was from the Lord I had to fight just
to be called the heavyweight champion of
the world because Don King was coming at
me with guns blazing how do you feel
about dunking today like not even what
word comes to mind with Don you know
just just not too good
there's not too good because of how
everything came fell apart at the end
after I never got a moment's rest after
one I had to defend the title that the
defender title to be be called the
heavyweight champion you know because he
made such a big fuss about big fuss
about it
does he have any allies today like I
mean in the boxing world people like you
that's this doc this anybody like Don
King and what do you know yeah it's
interesting to see because you hear a
lot of guys tell their stories and
there's it's like consistent no now when
it comes into dealings and he made a few
hundred million dollars off of fighters
a lot he made obviously off of a Tyson
but he made money off these different
fights ya know he got paid twenty four
million dollars off the fight would
Holyfield and then right after that you
had some you you your health was that
the whole issue I said I was got got the
press and put on a lot of weight went
into a diabetic coma almost passed and
had to get through that and then I got
back on my feet and came back and
started fighting again
am I really reason was for that was just
to get back healthy you know it's been
good ever since but but you did win a
few again you you went away six out of
eight or six I don't know what it was
six fights yeah so six fight winning
streak so and today you're going back to
you know you're coaching these kids
you're working with these kids on the
boxing side is there are we anytime soon
gonna see a movie of James Buster
Douglas a story and also also those in
the works now I mean you look at
Cinderella man that's a movie that's a
great move as a great movie I was a
great movie but that's a movie you know
you know absolutely happen it didn't
happen but
every way be caring about heavyweight
exam versus your story though I mean
your story if I let you listen to your
story your story's a similar type of
story something like that it's a
blockbuster story somebody's got to do
your story
yeah cause any talk is there any
anything in the works I do several
things in the works and hopefully it's
gonna happen here in a very near future
I'm excited about the future
that's exciting James what can people
find you is there are you are you active
on I don't I don't know if you're an
active on social media guy are you
posting stuff on Instagram Twitter
Facebook anything you're low-key this is
low-key we got to get you on Twitter and
Instagram we got to get you on Twitter
and Instagram so people can start
hearing the stories because yeah I think
it would it would bring back a lot of
the stores cuz I bet I'll I bet a lot
more people know you and your story and
they remember what you did then you even
know I think still today yeah and I was
pretty excited I enjoy anybody that said
I relate to you anybody that's an
underdog that's coming up you know you
want to hear other stories of underdogs
that overcame the odds and forty to two
to one it doesn't get bigger than down
right so brotherly enjoy doing that to
that 42 the one on ESPN yeah how was
that felt was great man we had a good
time we went back to Tokyo that was my
first time and since the fight you know
it was awesome man you know they didn't
built it up even more where when I
thought 90 it was just a Tokyo Dome out
there and then it was now when I went
back you know last couple years ago they
got a music park out there and a
condominium site out there it's like
filthy now what did you see anybody
there that was there at the fight that
talked to like was there any kind of
reminiscing moments or no no just
walking around seeing where that's cool
but it was a great trip they did a great
job with the document I was really
impressed with a very good job yeah when
I watch it I said you know what and
there's the footage they brought and
they caught from the past and stuff they
the way they put it together it kind of
brought the whole story together you
know if you haven't watched the story
the documentary
we're gonna put the link below I highly
recommend you go watch into 34:30 called
it's called 42 to one right is 42 to 1
well the champ appreciates you coming
out man I really enjoy Spanish this time
yes definitely thank you pleasures all
mine
thank you